I know when to welcome to this video or
shy so as my opponent again that is
going afore the last game I played I
really I remember there was a pretty
stale Petroff so maybe something else
this time so good I may know in Shiva
ring and going for my old line
oops okay well this is this is not bad
you know this is not a bad opening line
at all the caption but it's been such a
long time since I had this on award 9f5
Knight g5
oh I have totally forgotten anything
here
he tries to security wants to sacrifice
on h6
it's not not totally clear how to
prevent it besides taking on j5 which is
not really what you want to play I can
go King age seven this is where I can do
that actually it's not not happy with
this move but taking on f5 is so yeah
that's really kind of disgusting if you
have to do it okay so he fires away and
I don't think this is too great and
mostly weakens white
okay let's see get this over to g6
that's a good square
hmm
you can't play we can put this on g6
this pawn and in some cases which is
really quite irritating
ah this is the kind of positionally
would you like to have a bit of time
if it takes what okay
point Texas roopd two or so and the VP
stakes I mean that that must be fine
okay I can't even take twice and doesn't
seem to be any issue of this King g6 oh
is that too too much
I don't see why not prepare to page
eight okay Jade winning more or less em
that list so young check this
I would love to double on the edge file
right rook aged five it's not really
don't see why not
you cannot that doesn't win yet it's
close to close to winning rogue h1 but
maybe you can do I can do it a little
bit better somehow taking first
Oh cookies 6qd ate something like that
okay you know I can check here now it
doesn't really net all that much huh
weird so weird
I don't know if I'm witness ending I
have got so much on the light squares
them the pawns maybe it's a win but it's
the kind of thing that's tough to be
certain about with six seconds on the
clock
eight points to steer too quick okay
really not sure though I had something
better there with the age file open this
is a very okay line for what it is an
old favorite officials he played his lot
in the 60s but I have really forgotten
the detail something like that is
somewhat normal but I did not really
remember but the engine is kind of
agreeing with what I did maybe King age
7 is better here with hindsight King age
7 and I don't think bg4 is good that
weakens really a lot and I don't think
you get over that much in return
yeah I wanted to go f6 just to stop
everything but the engine says before
going for counter play I mean one thing
is if he goes to g5 and takes on h6 I
have g6 so it's not opening up the
position I can go before them and it's
not I understand what the engine is
about something like that and now here
like and you can ignore that ready ok
you always have g6 and that keeps
everything close ok I played
a bit more static with f6 and g5 now
yeah but I was thinking I just take and
then I thought this was rather helpful
but okay this is better than the game
for sure I'm that is that is true I mean
like when I arrived on f4 I felt that
okay this must be fine and Bishop c5 is
a good move okay that's good that took a
long time for that but it is a strong
move if I can get the bishops of the
position it's must be fine King edge to
is just really not good
take twice and King juice example always
helps a bit weird but then there is
nothing I can just to grab everything
the night here is such a fantastic
defender of the king
I mean in addition of being a good
attack of it so here check and now
doubling listen to even so convincing
King f6 immediately as given by the comp
oh yeah I just wonder ever had her okay
this wasn't good I think but I just hope
I never said I said supported yeah
here actually I saw that this works but
I thought I wanted to play from made I
saw that this works but I wanted to play
for made but this winning winning more
material I thought there should be a
maid somewhere and that looked
spectacular but didn't
there is just no checkmate maybe here I
can already take I only decided to do
that a bit later
yeah this should be a complete window
it's just too quick it's just it's just
too much too many points and too quick
okay thanks for watching